Ouais ?
Bonjour monsieur ! Voilà, je me présente, je m'appelle Obi-Wan Kenobi.
Nous faisons du porte-à-porte, mon ami et moi,
afin de parler un petit peu de la
Force aux gens. Est-ce que vous connaissez la Force, par hasard ?
Ouais
Mais, euh, non... Ça m'intéresse pas
Oh, vous êtes sûr ?
Ok, non, c'est quoi le petit délire là ?
Oh, il y a aucun délire ! En fait on regarde si vous avez assez de midi-chloriens dans le sang,
et si c'est le cas cela veut dire que vous avez la Force en vous !
Et si vous maîtrisez cette Force,
eh bien vous passez au niveau 1, qui garantit la possession d'un authentique
sabre laser, comme celui de mon camarade.
Ça va les gars ? On vous dérange ?
Besoin d'aide ?
On les défonce ?
Non non, Anakin, on va pas les défoncer, ça sert à rien puisque de toute façon,  Monsieur va nous rejoindre...
Non ! Non non Monsieur...
Vous allez pas rejoindre ces clowns ?
Nous, on vous propose de rejoindre notre
Seigneur Jésus-Christ !
Excusez du peu...
Pas pareil !
Mais en fait, eux, ils ont des sabres laser...
Oooh !
Ah, vous avec pas lu le fascicule qu'on vous a
laissé c'est ça ?
Oh, bah non bah non !  Absolument pas !
Bah voilà personne ne lis jamais le petit
fascicule
vous rejoindrez les représentants
légitimes de dieu sur terre et
vous aurez un sabre laser vachement stylé. - Est-ce que c'est écrit aussi que vous plagiez comme des gros Batard ?
Ouais heu... chez nous, monsieur, la tresse à la con n'est pas obligatoire
Ah oui les cheveux, super ! super !
Peut-être on va comparer les idées, Maître Yoda, Jésus Christ ...oui oui !
Ouais mais nous on n'a pas étés rachetés par Disney Ohhhh !
Et ....                                Ok ...   Anakin ?
On les défonces ?
On les défonces !
Et du coup c'était vraiment vrai le coup des sabres lasers                               Mais oui c'est vrai ... Il suffit de lire le fascicule !
stop stop déjà stop ...  je vais prendre votre fascicule       oui voilà tenez ...
le notre aussi voilà fascicule
Parfait comme ça je regarde ça de mon côté
que la force soit avec vous,  que
jésus-christ soit avec vous
Que la force
Que Jésus, que Jésus
La force, la force, c'est la force
vous vous dites parce que, ....  Nan monsieur
Et c'est quoi encore là ?
Bonjour monsieur, pourriez vous avoir l’amabilité de m'accorder un instant s'il vous plaît ?